focus on who you are serving instead of
who you're not that one sentence is at
the core of how I've been able to stay
so consistent to keep making content to
not give up to not get too discouraged
and to get back up every single time and
keep going because I focus on who I am
servant instead of who I'm not I just
recently spoke at Brennon Bard's
influencer Summit and I shared my
graphic of how I've grown over the years
on my channel every time I show that
graph they always always asked me how
did you keep going in in the first 5
years when you had no subscribers when
you had no comments how did you keep
going and how did you make so many
videos how did you not burn out how have
you made 12,000 videos over 12 years how
how do you keep doing it and I don't
think I'm super human I think I had
actually more problems than most I'm shy
I'm introverted I was afraid of the
camera I felt like only egotistical
people put themselves on camera and told
their story I hated my first 350 videos
couldn't watch anything back totally
embarrassed by everything I made and it
was 750 videos before I inspired myself
before I finally liked one of my own
videos like you know what I'm starting
to get decent at this that was a good
video hey it's Nina carmichel and we
made these videos because you're
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you need the push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
my husband ever car Michael and learn
how to keep going no matter what
enjoy
how do you keep going how does that make
any sense because I always focus on who
I was serving instead of who I
wasn't most of us just focus on who
we're not serving think about your
growth think about if you've made any
kind of
content you know at the beginning you
you get nothing right there's no
reaction there's no comments and then
maybe you get one comment and then maybe
you get five comments or maybe you get
10 likes or maybe you get however many
views on your videos right you got get
100 views on your video now that's kind
of the standard now if you get 20 views
again on a video oo that that that
doesn't feel so good right or if you get
a thousand views on a video or 10,000
views on a or 100,000 views on a video I
remember the first time I got 100,000
views on a video it's like wow I've made
it and then it's easy to feel like oh
the next video got 10% of that and you
feel like oh I I suck it's not working
right instead of focusing on that cuz
that's a losing
game focus on who you are helping and
assume that it is serving people I've
always felt I think some kind of
responsibility
or just gratitude that anybody would
care about what I had to say and that
you were spending your time with me uh I
remember my first speaking gig uh was at
the YMCA in Canada was at the YMCA and
three people showed up you know three
people showed up and I I just did my
best to give a great experience
experience to those three people and
then I kept doing it and and the next
time we had four and then we had seven
then we had 12 and then we had 15 and
then we had 20 and then we outgrew the
space and so then uh I went to the
boardroom of a bank a Royal Bank of
Canada and took over their boardroom at
night for entrepreneurs these were free
events I was putting on just to help
entrepreneurs I had no business model or
pitch just serving and then we got too
big for the Royal Bank so then we went
to Indigo which was a bookstore it's
like a Barnes & Nobles of Canada we had
you know people coming out and then more
and more and more every every two weeks
I did it again and more people came and
at the at the height we had the second
most number people to ever show up at uh
at the bookstore number one was Sting
when he launched the musician sting when
he launched his book he came and he did
a little concert and that was the number
one event in terms of the number of
people that came out and the second one
was my little
entrepreneur
speeches it's crazy when you you focus
on who you are serving instead of who
you're not it does a couple of things
okay number one it makes you feel so
much better about what you're
doing it makes you feel so much better
that that what you're doing matters
right we all want to feel like what we
do matters and if you're used to a
thousand views on a video and then you
get a 100 views on the next one you feel
like you don't matter right you feel
like you're losing your value because it
didn't reach as many people don't think
like that 100 people saw it be thankful
be grateful for the 100 people doesn't
that you stop caring about growth and
Improvement right somebody asked me
about satisfaction and happiness and
they said I'm I'm always always happy
but I'm almost never
satisfied I always want to be getting
better to grow to improve and it's more
personal thing of I want to put my best
effort out there today this video I want
to be one of my best videos ever and
maybe I accomplish that maybe I don't
but it's the intent because I'm never
satisfied with where I'm at but I'm
happy I'm happy as a human because by
putting out great work and by paying
attention to who you are serving I think
that's the key to to being happy to
being fulfilled to feeling like what you
do matters so it gives you that like
focus on who you are serving it gives
you that and number two when you focus
on the people who you are serving here's
a secret they take you to the people who
you're not serving
yet right if you love this video you
might share it with
somebody you you might come back and
watch another video and maybe you share
that video with somebody when you focus
on loving on your community it's that
it's that double whammy in a positive
way of you feel so good that what you do
is having a meaningful effect and when
you love on your customers when you love
on your audience they're going to take
you to more people cuz they're going to
feel the love and they're going to
spread it for you you don't have to tell
them to do it they'll do it on their own
because they get Good Vibes by being
being around you even if it's just
virtually I think it's really critical
people are really struggling with mental
health um in creation right now in
entrepreneurship right now it's a giant
struggle and I see a lot of my
contemporaries a lot of people on
YouTube giving up after a couple months
saying I need a mental health break I'm
burnt out and I've made 12,000 videos
over 12 years and we're still going and
it's not again that I'm super human it's
just a shift I'm I'm focusing on who I
am serving and who I am helping not all
the things that I suck at and how I'm
not growing fast enough because that
game never ends right it's a NeverEnding
climb so some years I do better than
others and some months I do better than
others and do I want to have bigger
numbers of course but it's not the
reason why I do what I do one other
little trick that helps a lot
is assume that for somebody at least one
person
what you're going to create today is
going to be
lifechanging assume that for somebody at
least one person what you will create
today will be lifechanging that if
you're making content and 100 people see
your video and you might think that's a
failure because you're used to a th
views on your video that for one of
those 100 people it's a life-changing
video My Hope my intention is that this
video today is a life-changing video for
somebody for for some of you watching
for most of you watching maybe it's just
another good video hey thank you good
good shot of anpress in the morning here
we go thank you awesome or you're having
breakfast or you're doing something else
you're driving in your car and your way
to work and you're you're listening to
me awesome amazing but I hope that for
one person it's it's a life-changing
video it's finally going to give you the
permission to go off and do the thing
that you desperately want to do that you
know is in your heart and has to come
out I I just feel that and I've seen it
enough over the years of people telling
me that my videos have had an impact on
them only years later yesterday at at um
Brendon Bard's influencer event that I
spoke at people were commenting and then
dming me on Instagram and sharing
stories of I've been following you since
whatever year and this is the first time
they're ever telling me right they never
left a comment on a video they never
messaged me they never emailed me they
never they never tweeted they never sent
anything it's the first time I've ever
seen their name ever and they've been a
hardcore follower for a
decade and I've had a huge impact on I'm
part of their daily life and it's only
now a decade later that I'm finding out
about it right there are people who are
like that for you too and we just assume
that we don't matter and we assume
because you might get a few less views
on a video or post that it's not having
an impact and not having a reach and
then you take that person and feel like
you suck assume that it's making an
impact on somebody assume that it's life
changing for somebody that you are
giving hope encouragement motivation
permission for somebody else to go and
become their best selves when you tie
your self worth to the results that
you're getting you ultimately are going
to
lose because have some days where you
don't get
results and it's going to defeat you
it's going to lead to stress it's going
to lead to anxiety it's going to lead to
what in the quit it's going to lead to
burnout the key to fulfillment the key
to moment momentum the key to sustained
activity and the key to actually loving
the work that you're
doing is reminding yourself to focus on
the people that you are serving instead
of the ones that you aren't rule number
two bring Value First this is the secret
to getting the head in business and in
life bring Value First you want somebody
to notice you bring Value First you want
somebody to pay attention to you bring
Value First you want somebody to buy
from you to hook you up with a partner
to talk about you and and a speech on
stage like you want people to do stuff
for you bring Value First don't go to
them asking for help first go to them
with value first so that they're
stumbling all over themselves to try to
find a way to help you out too bring
value first most people will never
figure this out most people will
constantly be begging other people be
tweeting at them and dming them and
saying please help me please help me
please help and I feel so I feel so bad
I feel I feel frustrated and I feel so
bad for these people who are just asking
for help because you know that they need
help but they're going about it all
wrong by spamming people and begging for
help you're not going to get it instead
Focus your efforts like you will never
get it you will never get it this way
you're not going to get to your outcome
you're not going to solve this problem
by begging people you'll get a little
bit like even Beggars on the street get
a little bit you'll get a little bit but
you'll never get to where you want to go
ever by begging instead flip it and
spend your time trying to figure out how
you can bring value to other people
first so that they can't wait to help
you out too I look at Instagram as an
example I can't tell you how many DMs I
get from people who say Evan please
shout me out Evan please talk about my
product Evan please please go to my
profile and look at my video and then
share it to your audience like that's
not going to happen that's not going to
happen why would I do that I don't even
know who you are why would I do that I
had to make a story on my Ig and save it
just so I can send
to everybody who ask that and I get
frustrated because I don't want you
wasting time for all the people who DM
spam me say Evan go check go check this
out Evan sign up for our service I dm'
them and say
John this is not how you win man you are
wasting your time this is not I want you
to win DM spamming people is not how
you're going to win find a way to bring
value first that's how you
win that's how I respond to spammers on
on Instagram because I badly want you
guys to win and you just don't know and
you think that that's a path and it
seems like an easy path G yes it be
awesome if Evan or somebody gave me a
shout out and watched my thing and
promoted it but that's not how the
process worked now on the flip side
there's a lot of people in my audience
who who I know who have given so much
who are commenting on every video who
are commenting on all of my live stuff
who are on my Instagram feed who are on
my Twitter feed who are constantly
engaged and constantly trying to help
other people out there are a lot of
people who I've never met face to face
but are such amazing contributors to
believe nation and for those people I
would do almost anything for them within
within a reasonable scope I would I
would do almost anything for them
because I love them because of how much
they've contributed to me they don't
even have to ask if I saw them launching
something say hey can I can I help can I
be a part of it can I be a testimonial
for you how can I help you because
you've given me so much because you've
contributed so much I want that to be
you
I want that to be you find the people
who you're trying to get in touch with
find the people who if they noticed you
if you got on their radar if they talked
about you would make a huge difference
for your company and then figure out
ways to bring value to them and don't go
ask them say hey I want to bring value
to you that's not it you it's your job
to figure out it's your job to figure
out how you can bring value a lot of
people come and say hey Evan I want to
work for you for free I'll work you for
free for 12 months and you can mentor me
and and you don't have to pay me for a
year that's not bringing value
understand that if you're coming to
somebody who had success it's still not
value you working for free is not enough
because it's taking up the thing that I
value most which is
time so you're going to whoever you look
up to if they're at a certain level you
go to Oprah and say Oprah hey can I work
for you for free you're not even going
to get a response back cuz that's not
enough value you have to really figure
out what they want what they're looking
for what they're trying to do and figure
out an angle that you can help them with
one of the best ways to do this are
around when somebody's launching
something if somebody's launching a new
book a new product a new service a new
shoe like they're launching something
they're in launch mode they're out
they're doing interviews they're trying
to get their name out they're trying to
build awareness for that thing that's
when you want to go and help them
they're trying to distribute this new
video that they've launched and they're
so pumped for this new book that they
had that they're so pumped for like help
them help them distribute it help them
get interviews get on their radar give
reviews go to their trade show and help
you know set up the booth you know and
help talk to people like help them in
launch mode CU that's when they're most
vulnerable that's when they need the
most help and they're asking people but
they don't know who you are yet that's
your chance to make a really good
impression help them when they are
launch mode and so pay really close
attention to what they're launching and
get in there and be of assistance the
second thing is pay attention to where
they're spending a lot of their time so
I would go to Every social media channel
that they're on these people you want to
get in touch with and see where they
actually themselves engaging with people
where are they themselves responding to
comments where are they themselves
posting content because they they might
be posting something on LinkedIn but if
they're not actually watching a comment
feed then your comments are getting lost
but if you see that they're engaging on
Instagram then go to Instagram and leave
comments there you want to be where they
are so use those two strategies to bring
insane value to these people and then
that's how you win because I want you
spending your time on the things that
will actually move the needle for you so
that you're not wasting your time every
single day begging people and wondering
why you're not having success you're not
having success you're not getting
attention from these people because you
are not bringing them enough value
figure that out and then you win good
luck also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three find your Genius
I like to say that everybody has Michael
Jordan level Talent it's something I
believe in I think I think you have
Michael Jordan level Talent at something
I think you're a genius a legit Bonafide
genius you should be off there changing
the world I believe it I think you have
that talent I think you have that
capabilities most people don't most
people one they don't believe in
themselves enough to actually go off and
Chase it and most people too don't go
off and explore to find the thing that
they have genius at that they could be
Michael Jordan at Warren Buffett at and
instead you try to photocopy somebody
else's life you try to be the next
somebody no you're a genius let's go
let's chase it down that's why I'm on my
mission I want to solve the world's
biggest problem untapped human potential
I think everybody is that genius and
they either don't know what the thing is
that they should be doing or they don't
believe in themselves hard enough to go
and Chase it down so let's work through
those two things whatever Camp you fall
into there's going to be advice that
will help you one you don't know what
you're genius at amazing what's the path
you explore you test you try people
settle way too early in life you settle
you settle how do you know if you like
sush you're not until you taste it you
don't you should be trying everything I
think everybody should try to be an
entrepreneur everybody should try to
have a YouTube channel everybody should
try to have a podcast everybody should
try to be an accounting like you should
try you should pick up everything just
to get a sense say yes to everything
once adopt that mindset mentality we get
locked in to Career paths way too soon
why because that's what our parents did
because that's what we went to school
for why you're going to now live the
rest of your life doing something
because you've only tried five different
things and now you're going to pick like
that's the recipe for disaster that's
why 95% of America wakes up and drives
to the job that they hate you have to
try you have to say yes and don't tie
yourself forth to the results you will
suck at the beginning whatever you first
start doing you will suck it will not
work out my first YouTube videos sucked
sucked go back watch it so you can see
how bad I was when I first started my
videos I sucked I was awkward I was
nervous I was introverted it took me 350
videos until I wasn't completely
embarrassed by myself 350 videos
and so the assd test needs to be do you
like the process do you want to go back
and do it again you may not have been
good at it but you do you want to go off
and do it again so like when you go on a
first date Nina's here hello nah hello
Nina we love you P her new Nails Nina
got her new nails when you go on a date
when I went on my first date with nah
the asset test is do I want to go on a
second date not am I going to marry this
person just do you want to go back and
do it again don't put so much pressure
that this has to be the thing that works
out and is the the rest of your life you
won't know you won't know at first
glance so you need to say yes to a whole
bunch of things when you don't know what
you want to do in life you need to say
yes to almost everything as long as it
falls within your personal you know
values ethics you're not harming
yourself you know most things you should
go off and try I think you should try I
don't think you've tried enough if you
don't know what you want to do in life
you have not tried enough I'm going to
put my phone down on here cuz my arm is
getting tired you have not tried enough
you have not tried enough and you need
to try more next step if you found the
thing if you found the thing you know
what you want to do you know what you
have potential greatness at you need to
believe in that greatness you need to
chase it down and it's hard because
maybe nobody in your family has ever
done that before right maybe nobody in
your family has experienced or any kind
of background in this before right
nobody's done it so it's hard but you
have to because otherwise you will live
the rest of your life in regret knowing
that you could have done more you could
have been great at something but you
stuck to this crappy job that you hate
because it was the safe thing to do you
will hate your entire life if you do not
fix this problem why am I going so
hardcore on YouTube right now why am I
pushing hard on Instagram too right now
why do three videos a day why do six
posts a day on Instagram why why because
I have a window because there's a window
on your opportunity because my window is
now because this is a magic moment for
me with with my skills and my interests
and my talents and my passions right now
in the world of Entrepreneurship in the
world of YouTube and Instagram how it's
all coming together it all fits
perfectly for where I'm at right now and
so I have to push hard you put the
blinders on you put the blinders on and
stop looking for other opportunities
it's right in front of you you know the
thing you have to go off and do go be
great at it and maybe you have to
develop the skills I had to develop the
skills I am not naturally gifted at this
go back and watch my old videos it took
me a long time to get good at speaking
in front of the camera speaking in front
of an audience not being afraid not
being always so introverted took me a
long time to get out of that but you
have to this is the only way that you
win you want to win you want to be happy
you want to win the game of life you
want to have a big impact you want to
win as an entrepreneur this is the only
path you can't just copy somebody else
you can model you can learn but you have
to figure out what is your circle of
competence you have to figure it out and
then you when you find it you have to go
all in that's it those are your only
options otherwise you lose and you'll
always know you're capable of more but
you're too afraid to go chase it down so
one if you have no idea what you're
great at you have no idea what you want
to do you're not going to think your way
through this you won't figure it out
sitting on the couch you're watching
this video you're going to get it by
going off and doing it you get an idea
you try it idea try it idea try it just
say yes expect to fail at everything and
just think do I want to go back and do
that again and if the answer is yes then
you go back and you keep going back and
you keep going back and suddenly you
found your passion and if you found the
thing that you know you want to do you
found the thing that you know you have
genius in then you have to believe in
yourself and you have to pound on your
craft and you have to do that thing
every single day to develop the talent
to develop your skill to be amazing at
that thing because that is what you were
born to do you're a genius you have
Warren Buffett talent you have Michael
Jordan level talent and you have to find
it and you have to own it and you have
to use it to become happy for yourself
and to make a difference for the people
around you and the world rule number
four take action most people don't fail
enough most people are so afraid of a
huge fail that they don't even try
you're afraid of taking a big bet you're
afraid of going into deep debt and that
fear prevents you from having the thing
that matters the most right now in your
business momentum you don't need to fail
big but you do need to start otherwise
you will never build the big business
that you're capable of building so I'm a
big fan of going from idea to action
idea to action idea to action idea to
action you get an idea what do you do
you take action teach yourself train
yourself as soon as you get that idea
don't judge it don't think about it
don't plan and Ponder and strategize
because your list of ideas is a mile
long and it's not going to get any
shorter you're a genius you come up with
great ideas you're going to keep coming
up with ideas for the rest of your life
that list of ideas is not going to
shrink so how do you start moving you
take action I call the 2% difference
instead of planning to get to 100% for
your idea what's the 2% difference that
you can just do something about right
now I think your ideas came to you for a
reason I think it's inspired why are you
thinking about this thing don't judge
the reason just go off and do something
one small conversation one small action
start building momentum that's the thing
that's missing right now momentum you
need more momentum you're a genius you
have great ideas you should be changing
the world what's missing is momentum and
I want you to find it so quick example
when I was on my tour and we're driving
through the desert through Texas and two
people came to my mind one was my friend
Mark dger who i' known for over a decade
and I thought I'm going to start a
podcast with Mark drer like that's weird
why am I thinking about this why am I
thinking about Mark I haven't talked to
him for a while while I'm on my tour why
am I thinking about a podcast I've been
I've been anti- podcast for so long
saying it's not my priority I want to
focus on my YouTube channel I want to
build my Instagram up I don't care about
a podcast now for some reason I'm
driving through the desert thinking
about my friend Mark and a
podcast what do most people do you judge
it you think about it you strategize you
research is a time for podcast how would
you make it work what's the best thing
to do just email Mark and say hey Mark
what do you think about starting the
podcast together and he said yes and we
started doing the podcast and we didn't
worry about having the right gear when
do we start the podcast now like when's
our first podcast this week let's make
it happen and marks an an AV guy
audiovisual guy he he he has a video
production company million dollar plus
obviously he wants to use good gear good
sound good good video for the video
version of it but we can't yet and I'm
only a month in on my tour so what am
I'm going to do wait two months until no
we we'll do it live on Instagram and the
audio quality won't be fantastic and the
video quality won't be fantastic but you
know what we're building you know what's
happening momentum momentum the thing
that you're missing is momentum because
you're trying to make it perfect because
you're going to wait two months to start
and then by the time two months happen
you won't start that's the problem and
so now that we're back in Toronto we
film it and we have three cameras on me
filming it and we've got high quality
microphones and all of that stuff and
it's a way better product but we started
if we waited 2 months it wouldn't have
happened second guy I thought about in
the desert with Jeremy Jeremy Stickney
came to my thought leadership academy uh
late last year September last year and
why am I thinking about him I don't know
I me I haven't talked to Jeremy since
this was now it was I met him in
September this was now what February
January haven't talked to him in a
couple months driving through the desert
and I think I want to start a YouTube
Consulting business with Jeremy I get
asked all the time for people to help me
with their YouTube channels I don't I
don't want to be in that business that I
don't want to be a consultant but that's
a business and why am I thinking about
Jeremy he was doing something else I
don't know don't judge it don't
disrespect it don't worry about it my
next step is I want to talk to Jeremy
I'm going to Facebook message him so
Nina's sitting next to me said Nina we
need to message Jeremy Stickney and say
J me I have an idea for you and I need
to get him on a Facebook live call today
and he was working like I need to get
him on the call tell him to take a break
I need to get him on a call right now
momentum guys momentum is the thing
that's missing right now it has to
happen right now your ideas matter don't
judge them your ideas are important
build momentum immediately even though
they don't make sense why am I telling
Jeremy to take a break why am I tell
Jeremy to call right now this has to
happen happen while I'm on this drive
right now cuz tomorrow I'm going to wake
up a different person by the time I land
in Albuquerque I'm going to be a
different person I'm in the zone right
now thinking about it it has to happen
right now you need to build immediate
momentum this is how you start projects
now it ended up working out with Mark we
we're I don't know how many episodes
deep on our podcast Jeremy said yes
after that call and we've been working
now he's gotten his first clients and
he's helping people build their YouTube
channels it's amazing a lot of the ideas
don't necessarily work out that's okay
you'll get some crazy idea you're still
building some momentum on it and maybe
it doesn't work out maybe Mark says no
maybe Jeremy says no maybe we do a first
podcast and it sucks and we both hate it
awesome how are you going to know by
doing right you're not going to know by
thinking about it how do I know if I'm
going to like doing a
podcast I can think and think and think
and think but you won't know until you
try you can't think your way through
liking Sushi you have to try it and see
and so this is why I get frustrated
because I think you're a genius I think
you have great ideas I think you have
Noble intent I think I think you should
be off making an impact and making money
and changing the world I think I think
you deserve that you should but there
are dummies that are winning off of your
idea people who don't have a big mission
people who don't really care about their
customers they're just chasing an
opportunity and they're and they're
making money they
are why what's the difference between
them and you they started that's the
only difference they started and you're
still thinking about about it and so if
you go from idea to action idea to
action what's this 2% difference the
smallest possible way to just build
momentum not strategize not think not
plan do something email somebody call
somebody take action man if you guys
just did that for the next 3 months your
life would look dramatically different
so how do you make the shift how do you
learn to fail more elegantly how do you
take more risks how do you say yes how
do you take action I'm going to give you
a three-step process that you can follow
step number one is idea to action right
that 2% difference I want you to find
something today what are you thinking
about find something today that's been
on your mind and just do something like
teach yourself I'm the kind of person
who takes action not just watches a
video and gets motivated and inspired
but does something do the hard thing
take some kind of action even if it
doesn't make sense that's the number one
gift that you can give yourself right
now today after watching this video or
even pausing right now and just sending
that quick email out or making that
quick call take immediate action right
now step number two is expect to suck
expect to suck one of the big reasons
why people are afraid to fail is because
you're afraid to fail big don't worry
about faing big fail small and expect to
suck like the first thing you're going
to do is going to suck my first podcast
sucks Jeremy's first call sucked he was
actually pretty good but it sucked
compared to what he's capable of now
like the first time you try to do
anything you will suck that's okay
that's it doesn't mean you suck as a
heal human it just means you don't have
the skills yet you don't have the talent
yet you haven't learned the thing yet
that's okay how do you learn by doing by
experimenting so if you go out and you
expect the first thing to rock then when
you do the first thing and it sucks you
feel depressed you beat up on yourself
you want to flip it the first time out
expect to fail fail gloriously it's
going to be a total disaster that's the
best right expect to suck and what that
does is reduces the pressure If you
expect to suck then there's no pressure
then you can have fun then you can
actually have fun and when you're having
fun and you're loving it you're going to
create some amazing things so step two
is expect to suck and then step three is
how did I make you feel you can win in a
lot of different things there's a
there's a million different ways to win
but you have to be doing something that
you love right that's that's a Common
Thread between everybody who's had
success they love what they did and so
you're going to you're going to try
something new you're going to go idea to
action going to expect to suck and then
step three is how did it make you feel
did you enjoy it even though you lost
even though you sucked you didn't get a
great reward you didn't get a great
prize nobody watched your video you know
it was a disaster but did you like it
did you enjoy it CU if you enjoy it
it'll make you want to go back and do it
again and do it again and do it again
and do it again and if you keep going
back and doing things again and again
and again that you enjoy guess what you
get pretty good at it you learn to bring
value to other people you're on the path
to now building a successful business
and so I did my first podcast with Mark
and I loved it it was fun it was a ton
of fun I gave Jeremy a whole bunch of
assignments and homework to do while I
was on the road and he started doing
them I met him once I got back and we
started the business he got his first
clients right I like it I enjoy working
with Mark I enjoy working with Jeremy
even though the first interaction the
first episode the first call was a
disaster and we've gotten a lot better
since I enjoyed it and so think of these
ideas as you're going on a first date
the goal of a first date is not to get
married if you try to go from first date
to I need to marry this person you put
so much expectations on it that you're
going to sabotage the date and when it
doesn't go perfectly the first time out
you're going to be constantly not even
wanting to go on the first date cuz
you're just you've taught yourself
because you've taught yourself that
first dates suck I never find the right
person the goal of a first date is to go
on a second date
did I like this person enough to go on a
second date with them if it's yes then
you do it and if it's no then you go
find somebody else treat your ideas like
that too the goal of testing out your
first idea is not just to make this list
of ideas and in intellectual exercise
you can be proud of yourself on the goal
of doing the first idea is just to see
do I want to do it again do I want to
run the second podcast do I want to make
the second video do I want to do I want
to go to that second event right you
need to try more you need to be willing
to fil more you need to expect to suck
at everything the first time out and
just pay attention to how it makes you
feel cuz when you find the thing that
you love doing that you want to go back
to every single day I promise you you're
going to create something amazing you're
going to create an amazing business
you're going to create a lot of money
for yourself and wealth you're going to
have a huge impact on the people around
you and the world can't wait to see you
get there rule number five the last one
before our very special bonus clip do
difficult things self-love comes from
doing difficult things self-love
self-confidence self respect all of it
comes from doing difficult things and
praising yourself for doing them I think
it's one of the most important things
that people don't do enough but I think
in order to actually make the praise
stick you have to prove to yourself that
you're worthy of it by doing difficult
things you can say I'm a badass
entrepreneur you can say I'm amazing and
I love myself but what your brain's
ain't going to say well no you don't no
you don't show me what have you done you
you're you're waking up and doing the
same thing you did yesterday at least
this is the conversation in my head so
by doing difficult things by doing the
thing even if you don't get the result
it doesn't matter but the result you're
tying your selfworth your
self-confidence to the effort to trying
the difficult thing to taking action on
a difficult thing that you were scared
to do if you woke up every day and did
something that made you scared that was
difficult that made your heart go boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom like that
you did that every day and then you pray
yourself afterwards for the
effort I promise you you're going to
love yourself I promise you you're going
to go off and do amazing things you're
going to take that idea that you've got
and go off and actually execute it and
actually implement it one of the biggest
reasons why you're not is because you
don't believe in yourself that's why I
think lack of belief is the single
biggest problem in the world I'm trying
to solve the world's biggest problem
people don't believe in themselves
enough the woman who solves cancer is a
manager at some restaurant and she hates
her life because she never believed in
herself enough to actually go down the
path that she should have gone down cuz
she listened to her parents and friends
and family and Society to go do the safe
thing and she's got a safe boring life
that she hates cuz she doesn't love
herself and she doesn't believe in
herself enough and so you have to do the
things that make you scared that are
difficult that are difficult it's not
about it's not about being Fearless it's
about feeling the fear and still going
off and doing it and then saying I'm
amazing because I tried because if you
woke up every day and did something
where you felt amazing that you tried
you're going to actually go off and
accomplish amazing things and you're
going to feel amazing about
yourself this then allows you to take on
more criticism I think people should
actually be harder on themselves I think
people should be harder on themselves I
think a big problem is people are not
harder enough on themselves but you
can't be harder on yourself because you
don't love yourself enough the people
who are coming here the people you know
sitting there on that beach down there
the people here who are escaping a life
that they don't love for the most part
why do people people go on a vacation
come to some amazing place like this cuz
they're running away from a life that
they don't like the people like that
they can't be harder on themselves half
of those people are already borderline
suicidal they can't be hard on
themselves they can't be hard on
themselves because they don't love
themselves enough imagine a a ying-yang
circle
right the more you love yourself the
more you are your own biggest
cheerleader the more you fill your cup
up the more you can be harder on
yourself and take more criticism and
feedback and
negativity constructive feedback
constructive feedback and negativity
right air quotes negativity the more you
can
handle because it's not sticking to you
because you love yourself so much you
need to be your biggest cheerleader as
well as your biggest critic and too many
people are their biggest critic but not
their biggest cheerleader the only thing
that matters is what you say to yourself
when you see yourself in the mirror
every night and every morning how do you
actually feel about yourself doesn't
matter if people love you do you love
you and
self-love comes from doing difficult
things and then praising yourself for it
and saying I'm amazing look what I just
did I'm here speaking in Puerto Rico at
Brendon Bard's Mastermind event and I'm
I nervous getting on stage I was nervous
and I'm who am I to go do
this and Brendan's giving me this
amazing intro about how I helped him and
how inspired he is and how I'm going to
change their lives and my heart's
beating out of my chest like holy cow I
don't want to disappoint people cuz it's
my biggest fear and want to disappoint
Brendan I'm thinking in my head please
Brendon don't talk such a big game about
me because I don't want to disappoint
people when I get on
stage and then I got on stage and I
delivered my message and I got a
standing inovation afterwards which made
me feel amazing but it wasn't about the
stand inovation it was that I got up and
I tried because if I felt the discomfort
the unease the heartbeating boom boom
boom the fear of potential
disappointment the fear of potentially
being judged by people and then playing
small that is teaching yourself that you
suck whenever you get an idea so that
you know you have to go off and try and
you don't you play small because you're
afraid it's not neutral it's negative
you're teaching yourself I suck I'm
afraid I'm playing small you may not
admit that out loud but that's the story
you tell yourself at home when it's just
you in the mirror that you play small
that you suck that you can't handle it
that you're not good enough and you
don't want that cycle to repeat itself
over and over and over and over again
and so when you tie yourself Worth to
the effort that I'm willing to try that
even if I get on stage and just vomit
everywhere and suck and do everybody
down I tried I tried my hardest I tried
my
hardest and patting yourself on the back
and saying I'm amazing for trying cuz if
you woke up every day and you
tried you'll vomit a little bit less the
next time and then the next time you
don't vomit at all and then the next
time you crush it why do you expect to
be great the first time you get out
there as adults we don't try enough
things because we think we're supposed
to be great you're not going to be why
you why is your first video going to be
great you will not be great you're going
to suck at the beginning the results
will suck not you as a human you're
amazing for trying you're amazing for
putting yourself out there that's the
story that's the P of yourself on the
back that you need to do more of doing
the difficult things tying yourself
forth to the effort not the results and
then praising yourself for doing it is
the whole game you do that your mindset
starts to shift your belief system
starts to shift what you feel you're
capable of starts a shift and in that
shift is your greatness in that shift
are the amazing things that you can
create for yourself for your family for
your community for the world you're a
perfect Masterpiece and a work in
progress both at the same
time so praise yourself for the effort
that you're putting in today and go make
yourself proud of
you your chances of success go up in
direct proportion to your ability to one
on pick the right things to work on and
then two focus on executing those things
it's so easy as an entrepreneur to get
distracted we love shiny objects right
we love dreaming up new ideas and
chasing these different projects but if
you look at a typical entrepreneur
you'll see that so many of their
projects start and stop and start and
stop and you take something 10% through
or 50% through or sometimes even like
80% through but unless you're willing to
take it to 100 you're not going to get
the results you're not going to get the
fruit of your because you're just
planting a whole bunch of seeds
constantly but you're never taking care
of that seed you're never watering it
right if you want to grow a plant you
got to plant the seed you got to care
for the soil you got to add nutrients
you got to water it daily it's got to
have enough sunshine you got to look
after that Seed where most entrepreneurs
they don't they're starting stopping
starting stopping starting stopping and
you never actually get to where you want
to go people talk about diversification
you need to diversifying you to
diversify and while that's really great
as an investment strategy if you don't
know what you're investing into it's
good to have a a big portfolio of
different things so that if one thing
doesn't do well something else is doing
well but it really sucks as business
advice because if you're trying to do 10
different things at once they're all
going to be mediocre they're all going
to be below average because you're going
up against people who are doing that
full-time and have their focus on it and
so it's much better as an entrepreneur
to one pick the things that you want to
focus on right and then two actually
focus on it do that work Andrew Carnegie
was once the richest person in the world
and he had a great quote saying how he
likes to put all of his eggs in one
basket and then you watch that basket
carefully right it's only a major risk
if you're not watching the basket if you
if you take your eye off the ball you
start looking elsewhere and then
something happens to your industry right
and so being the expert being the best
at what you do will always yield more
results more value more money to you
than being okay at 20 different things
be the best at one thing focus and I
know that's tough because there's so
many different opportunities there so
many different ideas that we come across
as an example when I got the chance to
work with Lily and I took her under my
wing and now she's working for me as we
start to build up her business as being
a public speaker Lily takes up my
Wednesdays and Wednesday was supposed to
be write my third book day and the third
book is something I'm really passionate
about I'm really excited about it's
going to be how to change your
environment how to create an environment
for Success from your morning routines
to your habits to your rituals to your
friend into the physical environment I'm
really passionate about writing that
book and I need to do a lot of research
to be able to complete it but I can't do
Lily and the book at the same time I had
that one day open per week cuz the other
days are full at least for now and I had
to decide book or
Lily and I picked Lily and so the book
is on the back burner I haven't touched
that in months and I could try to do
both but they would both be mediocre and
I want to see Lily have massive success
and maybe when when I can build her up
to the point where she's more free to do
her own thing and doesn't need as much
of my time I can go back and do the book
I had a guy right to me talking about my
Facebook strategy and said hey if you do
Facebook better if you change the
pictures to look like this and if you do
more live streams and give me all sorts
of suggestions and and they're great
suggestions this is the challenge like
these are great ideas but I can't focus
on doing that and doing what I'm
currently doing at the same time and so
you have to prioritize focusing means
saying no you're going to have tons of
opportunities come to you tons of ideas
that flow through your head that could
all be fantastic ideas but you cannot do
all of them right now so you need to
prioritize pick the right things to work
on and then put your blinders on focus
and just go out and execute you need to
be in execution mode you got to get that
thing done and it's great to dream and
it's great to have the big vision and
the big picture and lots of
opportunities but until you start start
acting till you start doing none of the
stuff is going to
happen because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hash believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
and if you want to watch Evan's top 10
rules for Success check out the video
next to me I think you can enjoy
continue to believe I will see you there
we all want to wake up and feel like
what we do matters if you woke up and
you felt every day that you don't matter
to somebody else that the work you do is
meaningless as doesn't matter that's the
path down to anxiety stress